just let's base it on celebrities for
example advances celebrity men crept
date
oh they date pretty little things that
are pretty skinny can we can we not you
maybe there is that's completely fine
celebrities are the like that that's
Hollywood okay but let's let's look at
the everyday okay okay wait wait let's
let's stop stop interrupting me okay
let's look at the everyday person the
everyday person on a dating app men
swipe right 45 of the time women swipe
right five percent on the time dating
apps we would agree is mostly about
looks right mostly look so who is the
pickier sex the women okay
can I say something though
um just like from perspective at the
minute I go to a lot of events okay
every event I go to
probably 90 of the women are beautiful
pretty they've got something big bum
nice lips the percentage of men
that are attractive at these events
compared to the percentage of women
uh no attracted
I mean I'm talking for my whole friend
there might be like a couple of guys in
there that oh you're sweet okay I'm just
I'm just I just want to do an experiment
here you know just an experiment I want
everyone to read themselves one to ten
honestly yeah yeah
to be fair to be fair I'm gonna start I
give myself a five go ahead wow go ahead
I think it's time for subscribe
I would say like a seven seven okay I
would say a good like a good eight eight
okay yeah I'd say that in eight so I'll
put some weight on eight okay ten ten
okay yeah
oh sorry go ahead and mend two men two
oh uh nine with a trim nine with it
seven seven without a trim okay 7.5 7.5
is that what five and a half five and a
half six okay humble seven okay strong
eight with a trim okay okay so all right
all right all right all right all right
outside of me everyone here rated
themselves that's a girl above average
um
yes so what's the average oh no
I think you understood the question yeah
right okay yeah yeah okay oh I don't
know I just feel like everyone's got
preferences okay no it's awkward okay
it depends what day it is today okay
[Laughter]
I need some volume
I'll go down lower a second when
personality makes it better okay seven
you said seven okay go ahead I'm
sticking with them okay okay yeah okay
everyone else okay did anyone switch it
why do we go through this again
I'm gonna bring it down to the six I
think a six okay okay you're pretty
sorry
she's not gonna have no baggage either
but my point is outside of Me no one
rated themselves as average from the
women and most people are not an average
girl so what's average then I'm not an
average babe I think most people are no
one thinks they're average
I mean I what anything average that's
absolutely fine but I know but the point
is like women tend to overrate
themselves yeah generally I feel like
the Girls Ain't Got Confidence it it
makes a lot of issues within the scent
and the relationship so if you haven't
got caught it you suffer in life if you
do not think how do you suffer
the second piece
it's from sucks from succeeding in
school as a child to like jobs to like
doing anything different you know you
need to rate yourself you need to know
to come on this platform and hold a mic
in front of yourself you have to have a
level of confidence you've got to look
in your mirror and believe in yourself
okay I I agree with you I think
confidence is important if if you have
like the stuff to back it up so so if
you're going to come on a podcast and
you can't talk it doesn't matter how
confident you are you still can't talk
if you're going to rate yourself a 10
and you're not a 10 like it doesn't make
you a 10. and that's fine I think and
that's why I said that's fine if you
think you're average because there's
some people that are average but you see
me
because obviously you know me personally
but I'm just saying that in a room full
of people that I'm not that don't know
me I'm not gonna water down how I feel
when I'm by myself let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question I do
agree that there's some people okay let
me ask you a question what celebrity do
you think is a ton I'll be honest with
you give me give me one please please
don't make this complicated I'm not
gonna make a complicated but I'm not
gonna lie to you okay I know you answer
the questions and I'm here to answer but
I can't I'm not a celebrity I'm not a
fan of somebody
okay let me ask someone else yeah can
someone raise your hand if you can give
me give me a okay Rihanna Rihanna do you
feel like you're as pretty as Rihanna do
I think that's pretty yeah
um I wouldn't compare myself to Rihanna
um because I just wouldn't I don't look
at other girls and compare myself okay
that's what that's just something I
don't do I find it really strange but
you know what we're talking very very
like vapid very very like looks based
only yeah yeah it looks like if you're
gonna be [ __ ] like
yeah why wouldn't you compare yourself
to Rihanna I don't do that not Rihanna
but on the base of this conversation
if I had to compare myself to Rihanna if
you not force me to look at reality
I say who's prettier I wouldn't say
she's prettier than me and I'm being
honest that's worse speak to your words
and I'm not even saying that just to be
difficult like I I don't want to be
difficult I mean it's just something for
my truth if you ask me to compare myself
to her I'm crawling back in the uterus
now yeah
I take my life back because she's a
she's sexy but then that's why well
before we were saying that some women
are delusional
I'm saying that to say that to say that
Rihanna is not prettier than you I never
said that what did you say sorry sorry
I'm sorry sorry what did you say I said
I wouldn't compare myself I never said
Rihanna is not is um oh she's not
prettier than me I would never say that
I've not I just can't compare myself and
you said if you have but if you had to
yeah
exactly so that's what I'm saying I
wouldn't say she's pretty exactly so
that's why I'm so it's very pretty
but that's why I'm saying that before we
were saying that some of the women are a
little bit the news
but you see this is this like honestly
I'm not even trying to be rude you just
proved my point that women are
delusional yeah yeah
and you're not like I'm not even trying
to insult your looks it's just it's
Rihanna it's fine
we got to this project
um
she's spitting but just to say I don't
disagree with you there are some women
there are some women that rate
themselves higher and they have nothing
to offer but I'm just here to tell you
ladies and gentlemen I am not one of
them
but you can understand every single
person in this room can say yours
but you can understand why some people
might think it's delicious
but that goes back to me I'm a
millionaire I'm a millionaire but if you
don't have money in the bank account it
doesn't matter
definitely
they're in they could be in a small town
in the middle of nowhere Hollywood will
find tens okay there are people out
there that can sing they're not singles
let me back you let me back you
died
so just because like everybody say
inside it doesn't mean everybody was
taking certain tests and stuff recently
and you get me like they was all wrong
so just because everybody's saying stuff
it doesn't mean it's the truth okay
like everyone uh Rihanna
okay me personally
I'm not a fan of makeup
no not that like I'm gonna be real
whoever said that I want to talk like
that's that's a bit insecurity there but
we won't talk about that but listen my
personal preference my personal
preference if I see a girl if I see four
girls
the one that's not got makeup on I'm
gonna look first or who has less let's
say that so you can't really be on iron
she's prettier than this she prettier
than that you're all cutting in it
because really and truly like you know
right how if she rates herself more than
Rihanna then boom but I think everyone
as well is confusing pretty and sexy
[Music]
you know Rihanna's sexier than most
girls
wait wait what's the difference between
pretty and sexy I'm gonna get into that
let me hear it pretty is your face like
that's how somebody looks at your face
and say oh like if we if you're all
everyone's all dressed up in like you
can't see nobody then like who are we
picking who are you picking sexy is the
whole picture
can I add to you what you just said
because yes I think they're they're I've
lost my channel
I'm gonna take a sec as many of you know
I was just being and on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible